the shock waves of the covid pandemic
have touched every corner of the globe
but now the latest data are revealing
just how unequal the burden of covid has
been
in this video we're going to walk
through some of those data on two
fundamental issues money and health
this is the pandemic's unequal toll
first
poverty
using world bank data scientists can
model the number of people living below
the poverty line that's on less than two
dollars a day in different parts of the
world
before the pandemic struck it was a
variable picture with regions like
europe and east asia seeing falling
rates of extreme poverty whereas others
like the middle east and north africa
and latin america and the caribbean saw
little change or even increases over
time
but if we look at global numbers we can
see a steady decrease year on year since
2015. that is until the pandemic hit
according to projections based on the
latest data the trend takes a
significant turn in 2020 especially when
compared to forecasts of what might have
happened without the pandemic
in every region we see a striking impact
researchers now estimate that the
pandemic has driven up to 95 million
more people into extreme poverty
the war in ukraine and inflation have
exacerbated this crisis yet further
pushing up prices for food fuel and
nearly everything else
what's more the projections we're seeing
here assume that inflation will impact
all demographics equally
but other more pessimistic projections
paint a different picture
next income
using another world bank dataset
researchers compared average daily
income with a prediction of that income
had the pandemic not happened
across the board from the poorest to the
wealthiest portions of society the
pandemic caused a drop in income
but the picture for these groups changes
a lot when you look at how they've
recovered as time passed
all income brackets have seen some
recovery but the pace of that recovery
varies wildly
the wealthiest have by and large
recouped their losses and are close to
regaining their previous track
but as you move to lower incomes the gap
between where income should be and where
it is widens and widens with the lower
earners having not recouped their losses
at all
next health
aside from the economic shocks of the
pandemic the disease itself had unequal
effects on people's health and data from
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention lays that bare
the covid death rate for indigenous
communities is more than double what it
is for white people
compared with people of asian descent
the rate is about 180 higher
other ethnic groups also experienced
varying death rates
it's important to note that these data
are age adjusted which means they've
been statistically corrected to allow
for fair comparisons between
demographics with different age ranges
disparities like this have been seen
many times before but the pandemic has
really highlighted them
finally the impact of deprivation on
health
this is another place where there are
many well-known links
social deprivation can be quantified by
looking at a few different things like
access to adequate housing education the
crime rate of an area and so on
these data are from the uk office for
national statistics
across health from liver disease to
cancer to cardiovascular disease even
suicide mortality increases with
deprivation
and covid is no exception
at the peak of the first wave between
march and july 2020 the death rate from
covid in the most deprived areas of
england was double that of the least
deprived regions
the pandemic has exposed huge
inequalities the world over and in some
cases made them worse
as the world slowly starts to recover
from the devastating impacts of covid
it's still not clear how long these
effects will last but so far the data
and scientist models are suggesting that
the pandemic will cast a long shadow